hello everyone bit of a different video
today it's not a review
I mean it's bit of a critique sure but
not really review something that's been
bothering me for a bit and finally I was
like you know what making a video about
and it does have to do with Star Wars
The Force awakens more specifically the
last Jedi and this video does have
spoilers for the last Jedi in case you
haven't seen it more specifically the
fact that the first order is not
intimidating menacing or otherwise
powerful and presents why I mean they
should be they're essentially the next
evil Galactic Empire but they're not
scary why probably for many reasons but
it will concentrate on a couple that I
feel if they change them it might be too
late to change it now since we're going
into episode 9 part 3 of that trilogy
but maybe if they've done it differently
leading up to this the first order might
be a more menacing presence of the
audience it's essentially the fact that
first order leadership they just scream
all the time I mean granted I project
when I do videos they're not screaming
see the difference I feel like the
perception is what we're supposed to
cower in fear because they had a bigger
Death Star but as Yoda said making the
audience's perception of the power and
presence of the first order isn't going
to come from first order taks gonna come
from how first order leadership conducts
themselves and first order leadership as
it stands now comes across as a couple
of emotionally infantile brats they're
emotionally unstable man children who
command the respect of no one that's not
intimidating to us the audience and it's
the exact opposite of the Empire and the
simplest fix that could have done is
just have them not yell so much
[Music]
the Empire radiates authority to the
audience therefore they radiate a high
threat level to the audience and they do
it without raising their voices better
said they do it because they don't raise
their voices
you may find ready screaming in intense
moments of emotional conflict simply
sends out the message that you do not
have authority control or confidence in
your ability to handle the situation or
solve the problem at hand therefore do
the people around you following you you
can't be a good leader have you ever
seen a youtube video or a YouTube
compilation video of people losing their
[ __ ] during a debate or any heated
situation they're just screaming making
an ass of themselves and you just think
they look ridiculous right probably
because that's the point of that video
the point of that video is that they do
look ridiculous well do it and it's kind
of funny we're amused because we're
seeing someone lose complete control of
the situation
now imagine they're the leaders of the
first order in your Star Wars movie
they're the threat [ __ ] thing sucks
real people doing it in a YouTube video
fictional characters doing it in a movie
either way we still perceive it as
weakness when you look at the Empire
these guys never yelled now that they
didn't have passion and their
convictions not that they didn't raise
their voices more mature about it they
were adults acting like adults running a
military and an empire they didn't
scream to make their points not like
villains can't raise their voice it's
not like people of authority can't raise
their voices there's a difference
between raising your voice and screaming
you look at Bane's speech in The Dark
Knight Rises starts out pretty calm but
you know something bigs coming the guy's
standing on a tank then by the end he
has raised his voice significantly under
you absurd
but he's working the crowd he's getting
the crowd worked up the crowd reacts so
he gets more worked up is this
perpetuating cycle of energy but also
that scene came after a legendary
representation of a villain establishing
his authority in a room I'm in charge
even charge
[Music]
one of the most intimidating villain
moments I can think of and Bane is all
but whispering in the same also the
first order could probably benefit by
not undermining the authority of their
officers in front of their subordinates
when this is happening to Huck's to
preemies distracted
in front of people who were supposed to
respect his authority enough to take
orders from him you're only harming his
image among the troops you're going
against your best interests you impugn
his authority that insubordination
starts happening then the machine that
is the first order ceases to run as
smoothly as a gut essentially Snoke and
kylo Ren they're just shitty CEOs at
least when Vader disciplined his
officers in front of other people he
just killed them he probably knew he was
like if I spanked these guys in front of
other people they're gonna lose their
authority in their eyes gonna be a
nightmare whatever just kill him he's
not the smoothest way to go about it but
it does cause less problems among the
masses actually there is an imperial
officer that screamed I want to correct
myself this guy screamed more than all
the Imperial officers who raised their
voices in the original trilogy combined
director cranek however gonna break the
fourth wall for a second he was written
and created in the current Disney Star
Wars world he was written with a
completely different mindset as to what
is authority what illustrates Authority
I feel like Tarkin would have chronic
shot after this outburst and I have to
assume that because even Vader
recognized Tarkan's Authority enough of
this beta release as you wish to be
clear Vader can kill Tarkin and
everybody else in the room but he
doesn't this shows that the Empire has
rules it has structure structure that
people in the Empire respect rules
denote structure structure denote
stability and an empire with that
stability that's scary that's something
that people should fear the first-order
Laxus entirely I feel like it's run by a
couple of kids with no chaperone in
short the audience needs to see the
first order as intimidating as powerful
but the execution we've seen so far
doesn't convey that to the audience not
that people didn't talk [ __ ] to Imperial
commanders Leia straight-up stepped up
to Vader and Tarkin but they both shut
that [ __ ] down later had her arrested
Tarkin threatened her home and then he
uses the intimidation tactic of stepping
in her space and he did it without
screaming I mean you can hear the
annoyed if not intense tone in his voice
but he never screamed and that's why
he's scarier than Huck's right as you
lied about where the
rebel base was and targets like yeah
executor Huck she'd crack you your mom
and Joe can he get all pissy and start
yelling again maybe the benefit of the
doubt here maybe they're trying to
appeal the modern audiences by having
kylo Ren and Huck's come across as a
couple of tweeters locked in a Twitter
argument where everythings retweets and
all caps the first order needs leaders
not tweeters I feel like looking back a
few months after the last Jedi came out
in hindsight this is one of the reasons
they probably shouldn't have killed snow
Snoke though he did yell like a leader
of the first order apparently does he
was the one he was the best hope at
keeping these two in line so our two
main threats among the first order are
Huck's supremely loud and kylo Ren going
forward a few like hawks and kylo Ren
need to offset each other I would say
Huck should be the stable leader of kylo
ren's with the emotional dark side user
but Hoxha's image is ruined beyond
repair in the eyes of the troops and the
audience that that's not gonna work
cause kylo Ren outranks him so what's he
gonna do I imagine they'll probably do
with kylo Ren what they did with Luke
Skywalker and Return of the Jedi where
in the end of the second chapter of the
trilogy it leaves off with them being an
incomplete piece of work at the
beginning of the third movie they come
in just this master of their craft
jarring then would be jarring now but
what else do we got the alternative is
just leaving it as it is
I feel like in episode 9 they could have
a scenario would be kind of a cool
scenario where you see first-order
officers trying to assassinate kylo Ren
because kylo Ren is just so unstable I
mean no one would have confidence in
that guy they'd be like oh I want the
first order to survive he needs to die
so there's good opportunity there for
that I just don't think they're gonna
show that and I was just something I
wanted to talk about for a while I just
wanted to put it into words hopefully I
put it into words
and after illustrate my point the empire
comes across as a solid stable
organization something to be feared to
cower before first order does not funny
enough this wasn't my reaction at the
end of the force awakens when I was done
watching the force awakens Huck Snoke
and kylo Ren I thought showed promise of
a good dynamic didn't by the end of the
last Jedi something was bothering me
about the first order and this is it it
can make some changes going forward in
episode 9 but we'll just see what they
do I'm not gonna hold my breath for it I
feel like in episode 9 the first order
is still gonna come across about as
organized as a monkey trying to [ __ ] a
football we'll see what happens alright
so the first order in Star Wars how do
you view them you prefer the Empire do
you prefer the first order it's gonna be
yet another attempt at starting a civil
conversation in the comments section so
whatever you think comment below let me
know the comments section of a Star Wars
video so should be fun and
always if you'd like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]